-Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, I hope everyone's
doing a little better
after last night's
presidential debate.
My only wish for tonight
is that you laugh at these jokes
as much as Joe Biden
laughed at President Trump.
[ Biden laughing ]
-What about those questions?
-I will say...
-Less than -- Sir --
[ Imitating Biden laughter ]
[ Laughing rhythmically ]
♪♪
After last night's disaster,
Trump and Biden both confirmed
they will appear
at the next debate.
Meanwhile, Americans were like,
"Yeah, you guys
have fun with that."
I can't believe
there's two more of these.
It's like getting
food poisoning at Chipotle
then trying to clean out
your system with more Chipotle.
The reviews of last night's
debate are in,
and here's what the media
had to say.
-This was the most chaotic
presidential debate
I've ever seen.
-What happened on that debate
stage was unlike anything
that has ever happened on
a presidential debate stage.
-That was a hot mess
inside a dumpster fire
inside a train wreck.
-It was undignified at many
times. It was cringeworthy.
-I'm at a bit of
a loss for words here
to describe
what we've just witnessed.
-That was a [bleep] show.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a good sign
when the presidential debate
gets the same reviews as "Cats."
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, it was like watching
"The View" on bath salts.
It was like watching a debate
between two deejay air horns.
[ Rasta air horns blaring ]
[ Laughter ]
It was a lot to stomach.
If the debate aired on Netflix,
they would have had
a popup that asked,
"How are you still watching?"
All this morning's headlines
were about what a disaster
the debate was.
Like, the "New York Post"
headline said
"A Hot Mess of a Debate."
Or a "Washington Post" one
that said "Trump Sets The Tone
For The Worst Presidential
Debate In Living Memory."
And this headline said
"Millions Stay Up Till 4AM
Googling
'How Do I Move To Canada?'"
[ Laughter ]
This one said
"Dew Garita Stock Up 75%."
And finally
this last headline says
"Priests seen yelling,
'Yes, today, Satan.'"
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
"Yes, today, Satan."
Oh. The debate was crazy.
Some people compared it
to a circus.
And get this -- during CNN's
post-debate coverage,
Van Jones shared a message
from actual circus workers.
-Circus workers actually
reached out to my team.
They say, "Actually,
we take offense.
We are careful
and respectful people,
and we work
very carefully together."
So the circus workers
are taking offense
that this was worse
than a circus.
-Yeah.
Clowns don't want
to be compared to Trump.
They were like, "Sure,
we both wear a lot of makeup,
but we pay way more in taxes."
You know it's a crazy night
when a guy on CNN
very seriously says,
"I've just received a message
from some circus workers and...
[ Laughter ]
...they're not pleased."
Of course, one of
the biggest moments
that everyone's
still talking about
is when Trump failed
to condemn white supremacists
and instead told them
to "stand back and stand by."
Here are some reactions
to that comment.
-It was really a sad night
for our country
in that the President
of the United States
would not dissociate himself
from white supremacists.
-Donald Trump
blew the biggest layup
in the history of debates
by saying --
not condemning
white supremacists.
-Yeah, it's not good
when you ask the President
if he'll condemn
white supremacy,
and the "Jeopardy!" music
starts playing in his head
while he thinks it over.
[ "Final Jeopardy!"
theme plays ]
♪♪
[ Theme ends ]
[ Laughter ]
Thank you. That was my
"Jeopardy!" space work.
I can do other --
-Hey!
-Thank you very much.
-You pay for it.
-I know, yeah.
I do other game shows.
I do whatever you guys want.
I do birthday parties.
If your kid likes a certain
game show, I'll do that.
You know, space work.
I don't bring any props.
I let the kid imagine
where I am, what I'm holding.
[ Laughter ]
Could be a light pen.
Could be, you know, a buzzer.
Could be --
It's just a lot of fun.
[ "Final Jeopardy!"
theme plays ]
-No, no, please, I can't do it.
Not now. I'm too busy.
My wife and kids are here.
Don't make me do it.
-Do it!
-Don't make me do it.
I just don't --
-Do it!
[ "Final Jeopardy!"
theme plays ]
♪♪
[ Theme fades out ]
[ Applause ]
-Wait. Please.
I'm trying to eat my dinner.
-On that one, it looked like
you were doing math, though.
-Yeah, I was. That's correct.
That's what -- That's
the whole fun of it, yeah.
I let you have your own
adventure, you know?
-Yeah.
-You're welcome.
-The Human Escape Room.
-Yeah.
-Love it.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you talking about my brain?
It's like a Human Escape Room,
yeah, trying to get out.
I saw that this morning
"Fox & Friends"
tried offering Trump some tips
for the next debate.
Check out how they did it.
-Here's my advice for the
President on the next debate.
One, interrupt less.
Two, let Biden flail around.
And, three, sum it up.
-"Fox & Friends"
is just slowly turning into
"Sesame Street" for Trump.
[As Trump] "Loaf of bread,
container of milk,
stick of butter.
Loaf of bread, container
of milk, stick of butter.
Loaf of bread."
[Normal voice]
And, finally, this isn't good.
I read that more people
are experiencing cracked teeth.
They're experiencing
cracked teeth, and the reason
is pretty interesting.
Take a look.
-One dentist says that
he's seeing five or ten times
more cracked teeth a day.
That's what's happening
with stress in the pandemic.
Anxiety can cause you to clench
or grind your teeth more
at night,
and that in turn
can cause your teeth to crack.
-Man, oh, man. In 2020,
even our teeth are divided.